and the effect of this is well everyone
gets to enjoy their ideology and their
delusions and their fantasies and some
people get free TVs normal people good
normal rail regular people in
communities get destroyed there was a
woman who was interviewed in Minneapolis
her community has just burned down and
she was sobbing because now she had
nowhere to turn these people no reason
is that gonna bring George is in a
better place that we are will be honest
I wish I was weren't your words because
this is ridiculous
these people are tear it up it's a
terrible video to watch something tells
me that woman's not on Twitter something
tells me that woman isn't coordinating
with the black lives matter organization
and then coordinating with the antia
organization and thinking about
revolution and we're gonna bring the
guillotine and finally down with the
system man and we're gonna bring Marx in
here and finally know something tells me
she's just trying to live in her
community
and just have a life you know and kind
of do the things that we all do in life
and these maniacs these radical
ideological villains have come in and
burned down all the places that she goes
to and all the things that she cares
about and she's the Vegas and they're
gonna move on they're gonna go now
they're moving city to city they're
moving all around the country but she
doesn't get to move on she's still in
her community and nobody nobody is
talking on her behalf nobody is standing
up for her not black lives matter not a
antifa not the white liberals nobody
nobody's doing that very sad meanwhile
prominent left-wing communicators are
encouraging the destruction Chris Palmer
he's a former ESPN reporter NBA reporter
Chris Palmer blue checkmark on Twitter
he tweets out there's an image of
low-income housing burning to the
delayed low-income building completely
on fire and he tweets out the phrase
quote burn that Shi T down burn it all
down so low-income housing in downtown
in the city burn it down yeah that's
right next tweet once the protesters
started moving out of downtown started
moving toward Beverly Hills some of the
nice areas in LA all of a sudden was a
different story says I'm as down for the
cause as anybody any of you clowns
thinking you're an aleut to Grove or
Rodeo Drive in Beverly Hills it will not
work out well for you trying to loot
Rodeo Drive is probably the worst idea
in the history of bad ideas I'm as angry
as everyone else but keep that Shi T in
downtown LA don't bring it to my
neighborhood not my backyard uh-huh no
you keep that in your poor neighborhood
but in my rich neighborhood no no I
don't we don't want revolution they're
just in your bad place he goes on you
bring that Shi T to our neighborhood and
I'm gonna have a real problem with it
there's a lot of people up here who care
and are angry attacking our neighborhood
kills the movement and disgraces George
Floyd this freakin jerk he actually
stands on the grave of this dead man in
Minnesota to explain why people should
burn down the area where lots of
low-income disproportionately black
people live but not in his nice
neighborhood where lots of rich people
and mostly like Persian people and white
people live don't do that now that would
disgrace the memory of George Floyd but
go burn down downtown LA he George would
love that Oh he'd be thrilled
[Music]
[Music]